وزاره الصحه منذ قليل تقول انها نجحت في
اعاده تشغيل بعض غرف العمليات في مجمع
الشفاء ماذا في التفاصيل وكيف تم ذلك وباي
امكانات نعم في الايام الاخيره نجحت وزاره
الصحه باعاده تقويم بعض غرف العمليات
واعاده تشغيلها خاصه في مستشفى الشفاء
ومستشفى اصدقاء المريض ومستشفى الاهل
الاعربي ومستشفى الصحابه العدد كبير من
هذه الاصابات توزع على هذه المستشفيات
لاجراء العمليات خاصه الاصابات التي تعاني
من بتر مباشر وحتى هذه اللحظه لم تغلق
الجروح
بسبب المعوقات والازمه التي كانت تتعرض
لها وزاره الصحه الان وزاره الصحه تعيد
تشغيل هذه غرف العمليات بالحد الادنى على
الرغم من انها تعاني من نقص الوقود ونقص
المعدات بالاضافه الى نقص الكادر الطبي من
اطباء تخدير واطباء جراحه واطباء اعصاب
واطباء عيون كل هذه النواقص او هذه
المعيقات بالض اضافه ايضا الى اعداد
الكبيره من النازحين المتواجده في مختلف
المستشفيات التي لم يعد لها اي ماوى ياوي
هذه العائلات بعد قصف الاحتلال لبيوتهم
بشكل مباشر وتدميرها بشكل كامل الان وزاره
الصحه اليوم وفي هذا اليوم اعادت واستطاعت
اعاده تشغيل بعض غرف العمليات ببعض
الاطباء الذين توفروا وبعض الامكانات التي
توفرت لاجراء العمليات تجرى هذه الايام ما
يقارب 20 عمليه في اليوم وهذا بسبب العدد
الكبير من ال ال ال المرضى والجرحى الذين
تواجدوا في شمال قطاع غزه وزاره الصحه
تحاول الموائمه والموازنه والموازى ما بين
شمال اقصى شمال قطع غزه ومدينه غزه ونقل
المصابين بشكل متتالي وبشكل متكرر ما بين
هذه المستشفيات ايضا على الرغم من ان وحده
الاسعاف تعاني ايضا من نقص الوقود ولم
يصلها اي نوع من المساعدات سواء بسيارات
اسعاف او حتى الوقود الذي يزود سيارات
الاسعاف الان هي عدد السيارات المتوفره
سيارات محدوده لا يزيد عن خمس سيارات
اسعاف هي المتوف فره في شمال قطاع غزه
وتعمل على نقل الاصابات لاجراء العمليات
ما بين هذه المستشفيات وتحاول وزاره الصحه
تخفيف الضغط الكبير من المصابين الذين ال
الذي نجم هذا العدد الذي نجم عن القصف
المستمر والمتواصل على مدينه غزه على مدار
الايام وعلى مدار 90 يوم علما ان قوات
الاحتلال من قبل اقتحمت هذا المستشفى
ودمرت الكثير وخربت الكثير لكن يبدو ان
منظمه الا الامم المتحده نجحت في اعاده
تزويد وزاره الصحه ببعض المعدات الطبيه
وعلى اثر ذلك ايضا اليوم وصل بعض سيارات
الاسعاف التابعه للهلال الاحمر لنقل بعض
الجرحى الى الى جنوب قطاع غزه الجرحى
الذين يعانون من اصابات بالغه الخطوره وهم
وحياتهم على محك الخطر بسبب هذه الاصابات
قد يفقدوا حياتهم في اي لحظه لكن وز
الهلال الاحمر بالتنسيق مع الصليب الاحمر
وقوات الاحتلال دخلوا الى شمال قطاع غزه
واستطاعوا نقل بعض الاصابات الى جنوب
القطاع لاجراء العمليات هذا على مستوى
وزاره الصحه حتى هذه اللحظه ايضا مدينه
غزه تواجه القصف العنيف من قوات الاحت
للال بطائرات الاستطلاع ومدفعيه الاحتلال
مما يؤثر ذلك على ارتفاع عدد الشهداء حتى
هذه اللحظه 12 شهيدا وصلوا مجمع الشفاء
الطبي من مختلف الاماكن سواء من حي النصر
او حي الشيخ رضوان او حي الصبره او حتى حي
الشجاعيه قوات الاحتلال تقصف بشكل مستمر
كل تجمع وكل من يحاول الوصول الى اماكن
انسحاب قوات الاحتلال شكرا لك مراسل
الجزيره اسماعيل غول كنت معنا من مستشفى
الشفاء في مدينه غزه